you know how to pay this you've been
getting traction you are going to finish
the game I was kind of freaking out and
needing the plan to be intentional I'm
supposed to be the man that's taking
care of my wife and I can't pay rent for
the next night if you will bother you
can have a fabulous marriage it's just
like it took all the stress I didn't
understand it but now we know why there
is a story coming father to care roll up
your sleeves and be a grown-up adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good we need to get control
when we did the class we cut up the
credit cards I took them and ground them
all up I looked at this thing every day
and shook my fist at it you're going
down you're going down said if I knew it
22 what I know now my life would be
better I'll try working telling the
truth and smiling while you're at work
you'll get a promotion in the money it
wasn't me it was a him we had to be on
the same page same plant working
together it has changed our life like
you wouldn't believe they're gonna
remember today we don't look back and go
that's the day mom and dad paid off
their house they were calling what you
know we are debt-free 45,000 86's 145
thousand ninety one thousand
thank you thank you thank you for doing
what you do go see somebody help us
this is the Dave Ramsey show